secrecy for a minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well it's wednesday wednesday
wednesday three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern eu
thanks for joining me on let's talk the
tony michaels podcast
there's a lot of news to get to
especially from yesterday
with the hearing out of the january 6
select committee and the testimony that
we had from the officers i also want to
get to
this simone biles story because uh
you know people just can't stop paying
attention to
why an athlete rather it's a physical
injury or
maybe even a mental injury would need a
break
or need to step away for a minute or for
good
for that matter uh injuries are a thing
in athletics
and why we can't wrap our heads around
having a head injury sometimes
a mental injury
is not a thing i don't understand that i
also want to get to
a story a quick story uh about um the
former guy
losing again the big [ __ ]
loser down in texas he's a big loser in
texas
so we'll talk about that too but the one
story i want to get to
uh and i wanna i wanna bring sam on we
haven't had sam
uh on in a while but uh hey sam how are
you
hi guys hi sammy we wanna wish her a
happy birthday everyone wish
sam a happy happy birthday she's like 23
or 24
right right right i wish right
right okay so i there was a sam there
was a story that i just seen
um that was breaking before i came on
here uh and i i think this happened
within the last hour i've been doing
show prep here but uh
dusty hill the uh bassist or and one of
the founding members of zz
top has died at the age of 72.
uh of course anyone who doesn't know who
zz top is
actually knows who zz top is just
because
of the iconic beards the iconic music
the iconic clothes
uh the iconic imagery uh and the sound
that they produced
um and uh it's a shame to lose dusty
uh i know zz top and dusty take up a big
portion of my playlist and my itunes so
uh thank you dusty for all the music
that you gave us because he will live on
not just in his music but in the imagery
of rock and roll
yes and how zz top change rock and roll
so what do you have a
favorite zz top song no whatever one
is on uh the santa claus oh okay that's
the sharp dress
sharp dressed man i believe that's the
one that's one of the more
popular ones uh lagrange is one of my
all-time favorite um but sharp dress man
it's it's hard to go wrong that's a good
one with sharp
sharp dress man that's that's in a lot
of spots
in popular culture a lot of spots and
because zz top is pop
pop culture i mean they created um that
imagery of
of rock and roll stars wearing cowboy
hats
i mean no one no one no rock star wore
cowboy hats and leisure suits
and drove those type of cars and that
type of imagery
yeah and they and you know what's crazy
there's a great documentary if anyone
wants to go watch it on netflix
uh about the trio uh the little band
from texas
but the the uh they stayed together
right up until now i mean you could
consider zz top right until now has
has been together this whole time they
never broke up they never
you know they they kept making music
they kept playing music so
that's kind of cool
you know uh bands don't stay together
they have their own little things that
they want to do but zz top was the thing
that was the thing so oh and by the way
by the way happy birthday sam
thank you happy birthday oh thank you so
i'm going to get to the news
we'll talk to you soon bye see you soon
bye
all right so uh
thank you dusty hill one more time uh
for for
being on my playlist you will live there
forever
uh on several of my playlist actually
and zz top lives inside those playlists
uh and and like sam said uh you know the
the santa claus
is is permanently tied to zz top and
dusty hill dusty hill will live inside
of our pop culture for
decades and decades and decades hundreds
of years possibly
as long as the former guy doesn't have
anything to say about it but the
good news is the good news is that the
former guy
is not having a very good day
really a good week um really not even a
really good year for that matter
it's been a shitty year for him uh but
but uh
he endorsed susan wright uh you guys
remember
uh a representative wright died of
coronavirus cover 19
um she reran in his spot it was a
republican
verse republican race
and apparently the the club for growth
was really encouraging trump to get in
this race and endorse
uh to get susan wright the trumpian
candidate to beat i think his name is
jake
elsie uh let me let me bring the article
up here
give me a screenshot of that there
there's axios headline
um and apparently trump and trump's team
is not very happy with the club for
growth
that they push trump into this race to
endorse this person susan wright because
she [ __ ] lost
in texas so trump trump is not the king
maker that
everyone wants to think he is and i i
think this is
this is going to be true across the
board i think this is the real risk of
this guy staying in politics and this is
why
former presidents normally don't stay in
politics
especially if the other party takes
power
because if you want to be the you know
the quasi
leader of the party after you become
president kind of like
maybe obama was when when donald trump
won
you don't really you know you want to be
careful waiting in the politics because
you don't want to be deemed irrelevant
forever
well here we are here's the start of
this
so in the sixth district in texas donald
trump his endorsement means not a
goddamn
[ __ ] thing not a goddamn thing not a
goddamn thing
in the 66th district of texas
which you know take it for what it's
worth
but he's blaming it of course on the
club for growth
for making him endorse the wrong
candidate which
if if he wasn't such a [ __ ] buffoon
and he knew anything about politics and
he knew anything about these districts
and the people in these districts which
he doesn't
he doesn't he never has he has only had
his thumb
on white grievance in this country
that's the only thing that he figured
out
when he came down the [ __ ] escalator
back in 2015
his white grievance he figured that out
he figured out that there's white
grievance and there's a shitload of it
and we're gonna talk about it a lot
today
but once he gets inside these districts
and
you pit white grievance against white
white grievance against white grievance
ah trump trumpism doesn't always play
well
here and i think we're gonna find that
out in a lot of these primary races
where he's endorsing candidates
and it's going to be good for the
country because he's going to lose a
shitload of them
but of course of course in this case
in this election of wright versus elsie
where jake
lz and apparently he's a veteran uh he's
not so trumpian he's
i don't know if he's anti-trump but if
you're not vocal
for trump you're anti-trump right i mean
if you're not you're not
bowing down in his cheeto dust shoes
then your anti-him is how they view it
that's where they're at now with their
party
and it was obvious yesterday when we get
to the january 6 select committee
that that's the case and i'll i'll give
you the line that i used yesterday here
in a bit about the cheeto dust ball sack
hanging hard on the gqp because that's
what it is
he's looming and he's losing
that's the craziest part is he's looming
and he's losing and they're still
they're still sycophants it's incredible
they're gonna kill their entire party
so let them do it let them do it
[ __ ] them you know
it's always someone else's fault blame
the club for growth for
making me endorse the wrong candidate
what a [ __ ] idiot
what a [ __ ] idiot so the next story i
want to get to
uh because this this story is probably
not going away anytime soon
uh as well as our our last story
uh on today's episode by the way this is
episode
29 29 weeks 29
weeks we've been doing this that's crazy
every wednesday three o'clock
four o'clock eastern three o'clock
central
every wednesday right here i mean we've
had a
couple snafus because youtube decided to
suspend me
but otherwise right here 29 weeks 29
episodes we're gonna hit 30 next week
that's crazy
that's crazy so go to the youtube
channel and follow us the twitch channel
follow us
you know download it on apple download
it on spotify
because i'm sure we're going to be
talking about this next story next week
and the last story in today's episode
the january 6th select committee
we're going to be talking about that for
a long time but this next story is about
the olympics and every it was
a question rather the olympics would
even happen we didn't know
who knew who knew if that the olympics
would actually take place
because of some of the problems they're
having
with the virus which is not surprising
we're having this
all over this country right now we can't
get it under control
but simone biles the
absolute fabulous
[Music]
there's no one that touches simone biles
in gymnastics
you're just not gonna do it i mean uh
um to be to be
straight i don't watch a lot of
gymnastics i don't know a lot about it
i don't know about the scoring i don't
know about the events
but in the last 10 15 years
the only gymnastics that i've really
watched
is her because she's such a [ __ ]
badass
she's a badass been a badass
she will continue to be a badass and
simone biles decides
that she's not going to participate in
the team event and again
you have to forgive me i'm not i'm not
an expert on the olympics or gymnastics
but she's a pro she's an athlete she's a
professional athlete
and she's got an injury
she has some depression problems
which is a mental injury just like you
know you'd injure your leg
or your back you know like a physical
injury
and she's deciding what's best for the
team it's for her not to participate in
the
team the team event
now of course the white fragility army
comes out and decides
she's not american if she doesn't do
backflips
what the [ __ ] charlie kirk
pierce morgan what the [ __ ] do you give
a [ __ ]
what do you give a flying [ __ ]
is simone biles decides not to
participate in one of the olympic events
what the what the hell do you give a
[ __ ] number one
and charlie kirk simone biles could out
american your ass
every goddamn day of the week in her
[ __ ]
sleep in her sleep she's done more
to represent our country in just
probably a couple months of this year
that you have in your entire [ __ ]
life
you [ __ ] nazi traitor the [ __ ] out of
here charlie kirk
with that [ __ ] and then pierce morgan of
course
anytime pierce morgan has the
opportunity to attack a woman of color
he's gonna [ __ ] do it anytime anytime
you know get him trending on twitter
because he's a [ __ ] racist
that's a good idea so here we are
we have to deal with the white fragility
and i actually of course
of course i did a little ditty a little
have you ever noticed today so so maybe
maybe what i'll do maybe what i'll do is
i'll go ahead and play that and we'll
we'll talk a little more about this
subject have you ever
noticed that white male fragility in
this country
demand that simone bile do [ __ ]
backflips to be an american but they
transform into a melted puddle of ice
cream
when asked to wear a simple [ __ ] mask
you bunch of goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ] them
well i mean i don't even know if there's
much more to say about it than that
it's absolutely insanity that simone
biles has to put on a show for
for white male fragility in this country
because she won't be american if she if
she doesn't
get the gold medal as if that's some
sort of [ __ ]
some sort of [ __ ] standard that every
american has to reach especially
a woman of color in this country jesus
christ
get over yourselves you've you've
banned a [ __ ] [ __ ] jesus christ
put your white fragility away
everyone's sick and tired of seeing that
[ __ ] no one wants to hear about it
anymore
we've done this for the last five years
we [ __ ] around on january 6 and now we
got to go through a select committee
because you [ __ ] boneheads
wouldn't wouldn't would just do a
goddamn 911 style commission
that's all this is is white grievance
white fragility
they're mad that that simone biles
won't use her talent to entertain them
and to advance what they consider
patriotism
get the [ __ ] out of here shut the actual
[ __ ] up enough of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] because that's the other subject
that we're gonna talk about today
is white grievance and white fragility
but here is here's the headline uh from
npr
simone biles withdrawals from the
olympic finals is spark
commentary around the world
and really most the commentary has been
hey
if she's injured is she if she can't
compete
because of an injury it doesn't matter
if it's [ __ ] physical or not
you [ __ ] boneheads if she can't
compete because of an injury
and she's willing to admit it
at a moment where most people would just
hide it and injure themselves even more
and not help the team
because you do understand that if simone
biles was physically injured
during competition in the olympics she
would have to bow out
of the teen competition and another
person who is completely capable of
representing our country
would step in in her place that's how it
[ __ ] works
i know that much about the gymnastics
team
that if that if one of the gymnasts is
injured
physically to where they cannot compete
someone else on the team who is plenty
capable of representing our country will
stand in her place
now whether they win the gold or not
what the [ __ ] does that matter
what the [ __ ] since when do you people
consider winning a great attribute of
america
when's the last time we really [ __ ]
won anything that was worth talking
about
jesus christ we're the last we're last
in everything
we got a bunch of [ __ ] running
around the country running around
getting people sick
can't figure that out helping their
trying to help their community stay
healthy
jesus christ we got athletes and all
these professional leagues
don't want to keep their their fellow
athletes healthy
come on the [ __ ] out of here it's not
that great
and i believe that simone biles does a
better job
at representing the united states of
america
than any of these [ __ ] could ever dream
about
she could out american you in her
[ __ ] sleep
you bunch of goddamn [ __ ]
speaking of a bunch of white fragility
[ __ ] let's talk about the
gqp and everything that's going on over
at the january six
select committee because it's getting
heated over there
uh it's getting heated um the
just just today we have some more news
about some lawsuits that are pressed
upon
congress people uh mo brooks
eric swallow has brought a lawsuit
against mo brooks for inciting
the insurrection or helping to incite
the insurrection
uh mo brooks thought well congress will
defend me because it was part of my job
it was part of my job to incite an
insurrection
and the department of justice and
congress is like [ __ ] you here's the
headline um this is from
npr politics again the justice
department rejected
a request from mo brooks for legal
uh protection in the courts related to
the lawsuit
that eric swalwell has filed about the
january six insurrection
and how he incited the insurrection at
the
at the rally you remember the rally
oh yeah you know giuliani trial by
combat
trump saying he was gonna march up there
with him they were gonna fight do
whatever it took
if mike pence didn't do what they wanted
because you know there was that delusion
that delusion
and mike pence was gonna overthrow the
government of the united states
and for whatever reason that scumbag
mike pence decided not to try it
i don't think it would have worked
there's a lot of people surmising that
if mike pence would have done what
donald trump wanted
then uh something would have happened
but i i
actually don't believe that that's the
case uh i
i do believe that we probably need to
have a few more um
guard rails there for that kind of stuff
to happen but
um you got to remember mike pence was
just proceeding over
over an oscar nominee uh envelope
revealing
i really wasn't making any decisions nor
did he have the vote
um and and it doesn't mean that the vice
president has to be the presiding
officer
it's just that the vice president is in
the chamber they are the presiding
officer that's all that [ __ ] means
it doesn't mean that he has to be it
it could be the next in line to be the
presiding officer
over that over that ceremony because
let's say mike mike pence couldn't make
it
maybe he couldn't make it and had the
flu there is a succession of who would
preside over that
over that proceeding it's a procedure
it's not it's not procedural it's not
legal he didn't have any kind of legal
ground to say we're not doing this
i mean if he wouldn't preside over that
that procedure then someone else would
have
so i i think but you know having guard
rails on that procedure
is not a bad thing maybe we should
consider that
uh for for you know future fascists that
want to take over our country
like the last cheeto dust kangaroo coup
attempt that we had so let's talk about
that for a second
because we we watched yesterday as the
january 6 select committee commenced
um we watched four officers that were
there
capital police officers that were there
that pushed back
on the manga queuing on trump-humping
seditious treasonous coup attempt
they were the front line and really the
only
line for that matter and we found that
out yesterday
uh in public out in the open now we knew
most the stuff they said
we knew most the stuff they said but we
hadn't really seen it in that format
coming out of their mouths in that way
and telling the story in their own words
uh it was very interesting
to see how emotional it was for
the police officers now obviously a lot
of
right wing maga tights oh look at them
oh
they're emotional about of course they
are of course they are these
these people were carrying blue lives
matter
flags they're wearing blue lives matters
and then they were taking the flag poles
that they had the blue lives
matter flags on them which is the
desecration of the flag but you know
that's that's neither here nor there
really and
and then beating the hell out of them
with the goddamn stick that's attached
to the blue lives matter flag
it's very [ __ ] confusing very [ __ ]
confusing actually i made a i made a
video about that can you imagine me
making a video
can you imagine that can you imagine
that yeah i made a tick tock
i made a tick tock about that so let's
let's watch the
the little ditty that i did today about
the blue lives matter
and then we'll get to a few more videos
but i really want to talk about this
january 6
commission and get into some of the
stuff that was trying to distract from
it
which didn't work i want to get into
that you know the whistleblower
people out there who were watching the
news yesterday know what i'm talking
about
when i'm talking about the whistleblower
but let's talk about blue lives matter
first
have you ever noticed that the only blue
lives that
matter are the white trump humping kind
you chewing on manga evangelical dumb
[ __ ] need to figure out what the [ __ ]
you believe
and believe that [ __ ] [ __ ] them
so so that was kind of my take on it
right
that uh yesterday we find out uh
there were a couple non-white officers
one in particular i believe his name is
officer dunn i don't want to get him
confused but i believe his name is
officer dunn
yesterday he tells the story uh he's a
black man he's an officer with the
capitol police
and he tells the story about how
he's standing at the barrier there's
maga
trump pumping queueing on treasonous
rioters
uh coup attempters on the other side
insurrectionist and they're asking you
know they're wanting through
they're wanting through calling you know
saying uh no one voted
no one voted for jill by no one
and he says well well i did i voted for
joe biden does
my vote not count and it's it now
before he says he voted for joe biden
he was just a cop that wouldn't let him
through
now as soon as as soon as they find out
that he didn't vote for trump
oh baby whoa whoa whoa
that does not advance our white
grievance
all of a sudden he's an effing inward
and it continued and i guess the crowd
started chanting started chanting
started chanting
um not that not that it's surprising it
really shouldn't be surprising that this
crowd
would would uh uh single out a black
officer that they thought didn't advance
their white grievance because that's
what it's about
that's what it's about it's about white
grievance the whole goddamn [ __ ] in
caboodle it's the same stuff with simone
biles
this white fragility if if if people of
color are
successful and strong then we're weak or
some [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] they think
it's getting
they don't even know what they believe
like i said the only blue lives that
matter
are then are the white ones that are
that love trump
if you're a cop and you're in you're a
trump supporter
then your life matters but if you're
not so white
and you don't support trump and
especially if it's both those things
your life definitely doesn't matter
we're going to smash you with the blue
lights matter flag and try to kill you
to get in there to express our white
grievance by overthrowing the united
states government
that's what it was that's what the [ __ ]
it was
they were expressing their white
grievance in a way
that they were willing to injure and
kill people with violence
there were bombs and weapons
let alone the weapons they were carrying
to get into the united states capital to
overturn the government of the united
states
that's what they were doing
because ah because
man white people just aren't gonna have
the
quite the percentage of power that they
might have
you know white heterosexual males take
up about
25 of the country
and they only have all about 85 percent
of the
the power in the country and that's just
not enough
that's just not enough that's not close
enough to a hundred percent
jesus christ bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
get over it
get over it that's all i can say pluck
your heads
out of your [ __ ] asses and get over
it
which brings us talking about plucking
your head out of your ass
um i don't know if you guys have seen
the clip of jim jordan on fox news with
bret baer
bret bear pushed jim jordan because jim
jordan obviously
got [ __ ] thrown in the trash can by
nancy pelosi
if there is a god god bless her i'm not
a i'm not a fan
i'm not a fan of nancy pelosi
but i am when she is the gqp
kryptonite and trump kryptonite [ __ ]
them
jim jordan gets thrown in the trash can
by the speaker pelosi
after kevin mccarthy decides it's a
great idea to appoint him to the select
committee which everyone knows that's
all [ __ ] [ __ ]
that there was no way there was no way
nancy pelosi was gonna seat that
[ __ ]
no [ __ ] way kevin mccarthy knew that
and trump knew that and that's why trump
probably called kevin mccarthy i'm just
surprising here but i bet
trump called kevin mccarthy and forced
him to get jim jordan on there
because last night when jim jordan was
on bret bear's
tv show on fox news of all [ __ ]
places
jim jordan couldn't even answer the
question did you have anything to do
with organizing the insurrection
did you have anything to do with it
couldn't answer it danced around
danced around well number one he
couldn't wear a [ __ ] suit jacket
but he danced around the question
couldn't answer the [ __ ] question did
you have
and it's a pretty simple question really
i mean i didn't have anything to do with
organizing the january 6 insurrection
i can answer that nope sure haven't what
me
i didn't have anything to do with it i'm
sure that most people who didn't have
anything to do with it could
unequivocally say well no i what the
[ __ ] do you mean did i have something to
do with it
what does that mean organizing i don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
i mean i watched it on tv
or i was there or if you're a journalist
i covered it
but i didn't organize it but jim jordan
couldn't answer that question
he danced around dance around danced
around i wonder why
i wonder i wonder what nancy pelosi
what kind of information that the
speaker of the house
the third in line to the presidency in
this country what kind of briefings
that she's been briefed on about january
6 that she would know
if certain members of congress possibly
possibly had something to do
with the insurrection and they have i
don't know maybe legal or criminal
liability
like mo brooks maybe maybe eric swalwell
hey eric
hey eric
maybe you should consider a lawsuit
against mr jim
i don't report sex crimes jordan
that [ __ ]
so there was that that we got to see
with the january 6
commission are they a committee
yesterday sorry it should be a
commission
we really shouldn't have this select
committee um
as as much as we need a select committee
because
republicans in the senate couldn't get
off their [ __ ] asses
and do an actual commission uh that that
that would produce a lot better results
in this country
maybe a few more people would pluck
their heads out of their asses and
believe it
but no no no senate couldn't have that
we couldn't have a a
911 style commission and the reason why
is because they're the [ __ ]
terrorists they were the ones flying the
planes into the building
and i got a video on that actually let's
let's go ahead and play that that
so i did a video back when the senate uh
was trying to stop and mitch mcconnell
asked for a personal favor to stop
the january 6 commission which i believe
the reason why is because
you know there's certain members in the
senate
that are culpable here and probably have
legal and criminal liability when it
comes to
planning or organizing some of the
insurrection especially when it comes to
finger pointing where certain
people were possibly whether it's
members of the senate or members of
the congress in the house of
representatives but i did a video
when they started talking about how they
were tourists not terrorists they were
tourists remember
this you know first remember remember
that day
ah they were great people lovely people
that went to the capitol
and then there and then when it all
happened all they were horrible
they were horrible we can't believe this
happened in our country a couple days
later it was antifa
remember that it was all antifa all
antifa no
manga no trump supporters every last one
of them
were antifa dressed in manga where right
remember that that went on for a while
and for a while for a while for a while
and they
flip-flop back and forth and then
finally oh they were just taking a tour
taking a tour of the capitol that's all
it was just a fancy little tour
you know swinging their clubs at police
officers yeah okay yeah tour okay
but i did a little video back then when
the senate was considering the
commission so let me play that
and we'll get into a little more into
yesterday about what happened in the
select committee tourism
terrorism potato tomato let's talk
big traders kevin mccarthy and moscow
mitch mcconnell
do not want a commission looking into
the january 6th treasonous insurrection
i wonder why it'd be that them and some
of their members were trying to
overthrow the government of the united
states
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock they're gonna let
the seditious traders vote on whether we
should investigate them or not jesus
[ __ ] christ don't like this 911 style
commission [ __ ]
that's because they're the [ __ ]
terrorists just think about it wouldn't
it been [ __ ] swell if the 911
terrorists got to vote not to be
investigated
jesus would have been even better if
they would have had a propaganda cable
news show
called schmucker carlson or some [ __ ]
like that
how to spread the fear and their
terrorist lies around to leave your eyes
it was just a regular plane ride on a
tour
of the world trade centers conor
mccarthy and all you treason is manga
trump bumpers in congress
go munch on a big bag of horse dicks
[ __ ] them
i mean munching on a big bag of horse
sticks is you know an insult a big
horse dicks when you consider who's
actually eating them there
but of course they didn't want they
didn't want the 911 style commission
because the 911 style commission they
wouldn't be able to block and tackle
inside of their their own chamber it
would put it way outside their reach
which
when you when you talk about republican
gqp
uh maga politics having something way
outside your reach
is just not it's just not something that
you desire
and the reason why is because when
you're when everything's built on a lie
you have to you have to re
reverse engineer the outcome because
without reverse and
reverse engineering the outcome you're
not going to get the outcome that you
want
and that's the problem that they have is
they tie their reverse engineering
to this [ __ ] buffoon trump
the whole time the whole time they've
always reversed engineered everything
everything it's not just trump trump
didn't just do this to the republican
party they've always been
[ __ ] fascist then veiling themselves
as conservatives
always
if they decide not to have the january 6
9 11 style
commission the the senate shut it down
so nancy pelosi being the republican
kryptonite the trump kryptonite that she
is
she says okay well [ __ ] you we're doing
a select committee in the house
[ __ ] that's what she does
select committee that's what started
yesterday
now to run the distraction yesterday
which honestly the the testimony
yesterday was
there there was a lot of emotions with
the testimony yesterday
a lot of it uh you watch liz cheney uh
adam kingsinker
get in on the uh the bipartisan part of
the action
you know they don't consider it
bipartisan because
adam kingsinger and liz cheney are
anti-fucking
dictatorial ship
they're anti-coup their anti-overthrow
our government
so they're rhinos i guess
if you're not for overthrowing the
government of the united states in the
name of trump
i guess you're a rhino i don't know what
the [ __ ]
there's no one more conservative than
liz cheaty
and she's a rhino get the [ __ ] out of
here
the [ __ ] out of here you don't believe
that [ __ ]
but yesterday to run the distraction
because there was a ton of emotions
happening inside those hearings
uh when the officers were testifying the
questioning went on their opening
statements
uh was up and down as far as emotion uh
i think i think adam kinziger even at
one point lost his
uh lost his the control of his tear
ducts over democracy
and so did the officers because that's
what this is about here
is rather we're going to keep democracy
or not and that
we're standing around watching 30
percent of the country
in our democracy trying to undo
democracy because it doesn't suit them
because democracy doesn't suit them it
doesn't
democracy doesn't suit a bunch of white
supremacists
and a bunch of white [ __ ] grievance
trying to oppress
others it doesn't suit them very well
especially when the majority
doesn't believe in that [ __ ] garbage
so as we're watching the emotions of the
up and down and the select
committee hearing yesterday ah the
republicans decide in
in the house that they need a
distraction they really need a good
distraction
from this hearing so the idea is
that the most treasonous of the most
trees in this
uh marjorie taylor green uh
matt venmo gets
uh gosar and louis gohmert are going to
throw a press conference
to support the criminal treasonous
trump humpers who tried to overthrow the
government of the united states after
donald trump
mo brooks rudy giuliani donald trump jr
incited him to do that
told him go go take over the government
of the united states
replace me as your king you know after
he told them to do that and then they
went and did that those
people the bad people that tried to
overthrow the government of the united
states they wanted to hang mike pence
they wanted to kill nancy pelosi those
people
those people who planned it and and took
and took action to take out that plan
green gats gozart and gomer decided to
throw a press conference
to talk about how badly those people are
being treated
oh god they committed crimes and oh
they're locked in detention centers for
committing federal crimes
that's how it works that's how it works
when you allegedly commit a federal
crime and you're charged with a federal
crime
you can be incarcerated
detained since when did we forget
how it works i mean the black community
knows how this works
all too well all too well they know how
this works
maybe that's the problem
maybe you should have a little little
compassion
for people tied up in the department of
justice or the justice system in general
federal or state no matter the color of
their skin
or where they come from or what crimes
they committed
a bunch of [ __ ] boneheads so they so
they decide to throw a press conference
you know these big tough guys you know
marjorie taylor green
you know pew pew pew pew pew miss space
laser
how she's so tough and she's not gonna
back down
so they start their press conference and
and an angel comes out of nowhere with a
whistle
and he just starts blowing the whistle
and blowing the whistle and blowing the
whistle and blowing the whistle
and he doesn't stop blowing whistle he
didn't give a [ __ ] he's going to blow
this whistle all day long if he has to
so they're trying to do the press covers
talking to the microphone
and the whistle blowing and there's
protesters there to protest these fools
because they are their [ __ ] fools and
there's nothing wrong with a peaceful
protest
there never has been never should be
anything wrong with a peaceful protest
no matter what you're protesting even if
it's against
my ideas as long as you're peaceful you
should be able to [ __ ] protest
nothing wrong with it i mean you know
there's some protests that make you look
like fools but you know it's your right
to look like a bullet you're right the
peacefully protest
and the peaceful protesters oh my god at
one point
they get terrified terrified of these
peaceful protesters these
these snowflake lip tarts they were so
threatening oh we were so scared
it was so scary we were terrified we had
to run for our lives
and they did they ran physically they
ran matt getz
uh marjorie taylor green they took off
gomer goes-r
b-line b-line for the suvs to get the
hell out of there you know to get away
from those
those those scary those scary liberals
with the pink [ __ ] hats on
so so they got whistleblowed i think
that's the thing i don't know
did they get whistleblown or
whistleblowed blown
whistleblown they got whistleblown yeah
i don't know the best part about it all
is at the end of the actual
clip that was going around the internet
uh was the reporter who has outed
several
several other politicians gone to some
of their their
uh uh constituent meetings town halls
and exposed some of the buffoonery that
these people say
um she's and i forget her name at this
point and
some of someone someone will put it up
there but
but she's running she's running after
matt getz and she
and she's asking matt gats if he's a
pedophile
mack ants are you a pedophile
congressman gatz are you a pedophile
are you a pedophile matt gatz are you a
pedophile congressman gatz are you a
pedophile
mr cats let me rephrase are you a
pedophile
and he never he never answers um
he never confirms or denies uh the
question
that that she is shouting at him uh
it's it's just it was it was [ __ ]
fantastic it's a beautiful piece of art
that that little clip
um to watch to watch these tough these
tough trump republicans you're never
gonna back down and they're gonna
you know if they have to use their
second amendment remedies and
all this garbage run from a whistle run
from a whistle
they're as scared of whistles as they
are mask
holy [ __ ] what's funny is the guy had a
whistle he was wearing a mask over the
whistle
maybe that's what scared him he had a
mask on i don't know i don't know
beats me how could i tell
so they run from a whistle uh and
all this this press conference though
this press conference was designed
to uh distract from the actual testimony
that was happening in the select
committee
and the reason why is because his
testimony is devastating
absolutely devastating not just to trump
but to the
gqp and the reason why is because it is
apparent
it is apparent from their testimony i
mean they even
[ __ ] say it in their testimony that
it was a [ __ ]
coup attempt the cops that were standing
on the front line watching these people
attempt this
were saying hey this is a [ __ ] coup
that's what these people wanted
they were telling us that's what they
wanted to do we were
we were protecting the building behind
us from a coup
a treasonous coup attempt that's what
the officers said out of their own
[ __ ] mouths
the ones that were standing right there
defending the constitution
because let's face it they weren't
really defending a building i mean they
were defending a building and the people
inside their lives
but really the thing they were defending
the most is the constitution of the
united states
because these people wanted to overturn
it because they don't believe in
democracy
they don't want democracy trumpism
is not a friend of democracy
it's fascism it's fascism
a bunch of [ __ ] nazis that is
why that is why this select committee is
so important
even though it's not the exact thing
that we need it's what we got
it's what we got in the world we live in
and it needs to happen and if it leads
if it leads to
uh other remedies with with with
congress people as far as legal or
criminal or you know whether they resign
or they're pushed out or
uh you know maybe they're expelled
because of their actions fine we need to
go down that rabbit hole as well
and if it leads to rabbit holes that
lead to trump and his administration
and even people inside the dod
because let's face it we have a bunch of
manga trump uppers out there complaining
that nancy pelosi is
this is the fault of nancy pelosi and
somehow she didn't have the national
guard there well
don't tell them about the fact that the
only person that has the sole authority
over the
the the national guard in dc is the
president united states
and the president united states at that
time was donald j trump
and i think that's what we're gonna find
out here now we talked to the capitol
police yesterday
who was on the front lines we haven't
got to the part yet where uh we're
we're talking about the people who came
in to clear the building
and to protect the building after the
fact from other attempts
i'm sure the committee will get there
though
but this committee the most important
part about it for america and for
democracy
itself is to
is to finally see that it is a
cult it's a cult it's a [ __ ]
cult trumpism this q a manga evangelical
trumpism it's a [ __ ] cult
and it's fascism because
truth truth is no friend of fascism
fascism hates the truth
and the khan the khan the lie
the lie that is built to instill fascism
that is a cult it's a [ __ ] cult
and the cheeto dust ball sack hangs hard
on the gqp
and i said in my video yesterday so
let's watch
let's watch the [ __ ] rant about the
january 6th select
committee and some of the testimony
yesterday and we'll talk about it and
finish up the show
on the other side colt 45 let's talk
cheeto dust ball sec hangs hard on the
gqp
as the january 6 select committee
commences today
with the u.s capitol police officers
testimony it sure does not seem like
blue lives matter
you know the non-white kind their
witness statements they call the
insurrection
a treasonous coup attempt because that's
what the [ __ ] it is
why do you think the treasonous
republicans don't want the american
people to hear the truth about their
mussolini jesus
with fascists truth is the enemy and the
khan is a cult
it's a [ __ ] cult hey you timothy
mctrump humping traitors
the truth is it was a [ __ ] cheeto
dust coup attempt
pluck your head out of your [ __ ]
asses
[ __ ] them there you have it
and i think i think the officers did a
good job yesterday
at making sure the american people
understood what the front line was
what they were hearing on the front line
and what the intent of those
people who were pushing on the front
line were
i think they did a damn good job at
expressing to the american people
not only not only about the people
standing there pushing them wanting to
overthrow
the the constitution the united states
but why
they were there and who sent them the
hitman
as they referred to him the hitman
who sent them who sent them to do what
they did
and that is why that is why we need to
pressure pressure pressure pressure this
committee
to do everything it can about subpoenas
i don't care if it's members of congress
if it's the senate if it's members of
the administration
doj dod the capitol police whoever it is
[Music]
the former president of the united
states
he can he can bring a a diaper bag with
him that day
and do the same thing hillary clinton
did and do hours and hours and hours of
testimony
just need to make sure we give him
plenty of breaks to change his diapers
that [ __ ]
so whatever they have to do to subpoena
these son of a [ __ ] to get to the
truth
forget about forget about oh it's it's
not it's not by patterson it's all
politics well you [ __ ] mean it
that way
you [ __ ] mean it that way
so use that subpoena power to the
fullest extent
and set his shitty diaper ass in the
chair
along with rudy giuliani donald trump jr
mo brooks
jim jordan anyone else charlie kirk for
that matter
that [ __ ] they all paid alex
jones
they paid for this to happen
they gave the money to make sure these
people were organized to overturn the
the government of the united states so
donald trump could remain king
a coup a cheeto dust kangaroo
coup that's what it was
was an attempt to overthrow the
government of the united states
now they failed miserably of course
because trump was behind it
but they failed miserably
but the whole thing leading up to
january 6
after the election after he knew he lost
leading up to january 6 january 6 itself
and then this continued barrage of how
they they still
won even though they [ __ ] lost that
the arizona audit the
all the [ __ ] all the court cases all
the nonsense
he won he no he didn't he you guys
cheated and if
and even if [ __ ] democrats and
liberals cheated don't you think we
would have took more than
50 [ __ ] seats in the senate
wait i mean
if if if if i had george soros's ear
i would have told georgie hey georgie
it would be nice to have 60 it would be
good to have 60. so as long as you're
as long as you're framing it up and
you're cheating here let's cheat and get
60 seats
let's get a super majority that way we
could really [ __ ] them up
if that was the case would wouldn't that
be the case i mean
if we're actually going to cheat let's
cheat so we can win not just
cheat so it looks like we won let's
actually get some [ __ ] done
because all of it all of it
front to the back from the election day
leading up to january 6th the events on
january 6 that
the cheeto dust kangaroo coo attempt
and then everything all the whining
afterwards all the whining afterwards
is all white fragility and white
grievance
all of it all of it has nothing to do
with votes there's nothing to do with
winning and losing
because this is morons losing in texas
he can't even
he can't even win an endorsed candidate
in texas in the sixth district
where the club for growth wants him to
back somebody
for [ __ ] sake the wife of the dead
congressman who died from coven 19 in
texas
the wife of the sitting person
the club for growth and donald trump
can't even imagine can't even manage to
win that race
in texas texas
they're losing in texas that's where
trumpism
is losing
so all this all of it all of it
is all white fragility and white
grievance
has nothing to do with anything else but
that
and the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty because what
we strive for in this country is liberty
not white not white supremacy not
white grievance not white fragility
it's liberty liberty is what we strive
for
and freedom and rights are our vehicle
to get there
and let's hope and let's let's make sure
especially if it doesn't happen this way
that we pile up a mountain of [ __ ]
votes on these son of a [ __ ]
that's what we have to do that's our
responsibility here
and it all and all of it is to vote
vote vote vote vote and keep voting
[ __ ] them vote vote vote vote [ __ ] them
and we can't get to [ __ ] picky
if it ain't trump
vote vote
vote vote vote don't vote gqp
but don't get too picky with who the
democrat is
because you do not want the gqp taking
power again
we would it we may not have a
constitution
that's what they wanted they wanted to
burn the constitution on january 6th
and the reason why is because the
constitution does not suit their needs
it does not suit their values anymore if
they ever had any
the constitution the way that it's
framed
with liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
as it's in goal through freedom and
rights
does not it does it does not support
white supremacy white fragility and
white grievance it does not
because the majority of americans think
that's all [ __ ]
there's not even i don't even believe
there's a majority of white people that
believe that
[ __ ] anymore it's just the loud ones
it's the loud ones the ones still
yelling and screaming and we've always
had this we've always had this with any
[ __ ] issue that we go through
rather it was the revolution rather it
was a civil war rather with civil rights
women's rights
we always had this this portion of the
country that just
is not tolerant and we need to not
we need to be intolerant of the
intolerant [ __ ] them
i guess that's what [ __ ] is about and
the january 6
select committee should get to the
bottom
of every single part of planning
to overthrow the united states
government our government
we the people's government our democracy
our democratic republic in the name
of white grievance now
we need to know who it was what it was
where it was
who paid for it how it happened i don't
give a [ __ ] who you question
go to the end of the line if you have to
all the way to trump
subpoena that [ __ ] and then
if it's criminal arrest those son of a
[ __ ]
arrest them and try them do it
enough is enough of this treasonous
seditious [ __ ]
no more cheeto dust kangaroo
coup attempts [ __ ] them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them